[Music]
Frozen is a worldwide phenomenon the two
movies are among Disney's biggest hits
and are loved by all age groups the
first Frozen movie was released 10 years
ago and dominated at the box office as
well as with the song Let It Go the
sequel Frozen 2 was just as successful
in 2019 of course this raises one
question in particular when will Frozen
3 be released production is already in
full swing and there is currently a good
chance that Frozen 3 will hit theaters
in 2025 find out all the latest details
about the sequel to The Animated
Adventure in this
preview of course many people are
wondering what the plot of Frozen 3 will
consist of Disney is still working on
this at present so there is no official
information yet nevertheless there are
some plausible ways in which the story
could continue for example there is a
new love story in the pipeline Queen
Anna seems to have settled her life with
Kristoff but something also seems to be
in the offing for Elsa in the second
part namely with the north Aldren girl
honey Marin Elsa voice actress Aden
Manzel already stated in the runup to
Frozen 2 that the relationship between
the two seemed to point to a love story
in the third part and we all know Love
is an Open Door hopefully we will see
Anna and Kristoff's wedding after all
they got engaged at the end of the
second part perhaps the two of them will
also have Royal Offspring who will play
a role in Frozen 3 some speculate that
Hans could make a comeback as a villain
and is plotting to overthrow the Two
Sisters while in Exile he is the
youngest of the 12 brothers from the
royal family of the Southern Isles he
will certainly not be able to enter
Arendelle as easily but the Enchanted
Forest has opened up A New Path for him
a very far-fetched but nevertheless
exciting Theory would be that Anna has
secret powers that she doesn't know
about yet there is speculation on the
internet that Anna may have the ability
to control fire the movies do provide
some clues for example the fact that
Anna has reddish hair while Elsa has
white hair to match her ice powers their
personalities also match their abilities
while Elsa appears calm and reserved and
appears somewhat cold Anna is vibrant
and impulsive the interaction of Ice and
Fire could lead to a lot of chaos and
this scenario would would certainly make
for a captivating plot no matter how
exactly the storyline turns out in the
end we are certain that Snowman Olaf is
sure to make us laugh a little as long
as this fan favorite is around hardly
anything can go wrong
right before the new movie hits Cinemas
another adventure from the Frozen world
is being released a 12-part podcast with
the title forces of nature this podcast
picks up on the events of the second
film and is intended to connect to
Frozen 3 it is about the chaos caused by
mysterious copper machines in the forest
Anna an El are faced with the task of
solving the mystery of these machines
and receive support from old and new
friends there is a good chance that
these new characters will also play a
part in Frozen 3 firstly there is the
Curious Queen daa who approaches
everything in an extremely scientific
manner Lord Wolf Gang is the nephew of
the Duke of westleton and is very
helpful there are also two magpies
called astd and Magnus who are anything
but ordinary the podcast started in
October 2023 and new episodes are being
released weekly we are certain that the
new characters will also be properly
introduced in the feature
film the movie is still in the early
stages of production but one major
change is already known Jennifer Lee the
screenwriter and director of the first
two movies will no longer be taking on
these duties and it remains a secret who
will take her place but she will surely
not be leaving completely as Disney's
Chief creative officer she will probably
take on an advisory role she's already
expressed her excitement about the
current status of the movie to the Press
there is still no official release date
for Frozen 3 but there are many signs
that the movie will be released in
November 2025 part one was released in
theaters in November 2013 part two came
6 years later in November 2019 another 6
years later we end up in November 2025
the timing would usus not only be
traditional but it would also fit
perfectly early production has already
in progress and the movie would
therefore still have about 2 years left
until release besides late fall is the
ideal time to get into the Christmas
spirit with the wintry Snow
Queen one thing is clear Frozen 3 is
highly anticipated and is bound to be
another big hit at the box office what
do you think of the movie series is
frozen delivering exactly what you
expect from Disney movies or would you
prefer a different approach to animated
films let us know your views in the
[Music]
comments